this current president joe biden you
want to talk about
binary choices you want this if you did
not support trump in 2020 you supported
this guy
and
and and so behold
the great
dignified
mature responsible president
that you helped to elect
i don't want to get going because i
don't keep you here too long because you
know all i'm about to have i've said you
know what i've done and you know what
we're doing and you know i know what
you're doing um yes i as franklin
roosevelt frankly very famously said
we have nothing to fear but fear itself
and ronald reagan famously said mr
gorbachev tear down
this wall
and i'm sure we will be reciting this
for many years to come joe biden
famously said play it again i don't want
to get going because i don't keep you
here too long because you know all i'm
about to have i've said you know what
i've done and you know what we're doing
and you know i know what you're doing
i don't i don't want to get going
because you know and hear what and what
i said but we all we know all
you know and i and i know and you know
and i know what you're doing
there there actually is
a a weird kind of coherence to this
the the key word or the key phrase here
is you know
and you know and you all know and you
all know and and you know all and i know
and you know that i know and i know that
you know
what the you know
signifies
is
biden's confidence that he won't be
called out by the press
if any republican sounded like this you
would have a call to
to
remove him from office for mental
incapacitation
for any republican president and you
actually did get some of these calls
when donald trump said far more coherent
things
when he was in office
but the you know that you know that you
know that you know that i know that you
know signifies that look we're on the
same team press
you're not going to call me out
it's okay it's cool we all know what
we're doing because we're on the same
team
i'm glad that you liked that clip
i like that you like that clip
if you want to get more clips you got to
ring that bell you got to subscribe get
the notifications if you don't get the
notifications for whatever reason
youtube
then you should head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
podcast leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]